-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
That sounded so good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone is talking about this.
Yesterday, billionaire
Richard Branson went to space
on one of his
Virgin Galactic rockets.
Branson's trip to space
only lasted about four minutes,
which is honestly
pretty good for a virgin.
And, uh...
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Virgin Galactic made history
by launching
the first goatee into space.
[ Laughter ]
You know these are crazy times
when it's safer flying to space
than going on a Carnival cruise,
don't you think?
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Branson went
with two pilots
and three of his employees.
So if you think it's awkward
riding an elevator
with your boss,
try going to space.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
the flight went more than
50 miles high
to the edge of space.
Southwest heard and was like,
"Big deal.
We did that last week when one
of our pilots fell asleep."
[ Laughter ]
"And look to your left, you can
see the curvature of the Earth."
[ Laughter ]
Actually, I got a little choked
up watching Branson's flight.
It always warms my heart
to see billionaires
achieve their dreams.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
He bought a planet!
He always wanted to buy one
and he bought one,
bought a planet.
[ Laughter ]
But I was happy for him, though.
Normally when a billionaire
flies away faster
than the speed of sound,
it's 'cause they just got linked
to Jeffrey Epstein.
So, you know...
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Oh! Oh!
-[ Laughing ]
-Wow!
-Isn't live comedy fun?
Isn't it great?
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.
That's what I love.
I love you guys.
It was a pretty cool moment.
I was a little surprised
by that one part, though.
Did you see this?
Watch this.
-Three, two, one.
Release, release, release.
Ignition.
Good rocket motor burn.
Everything's looking
really good in space.
[ Laughter ]
-Just a little...
Come on.
You don't need to do that.
-There's no need.
-That's right, Branson beat
Jeff Bezos to space.
That's why Branson got home
and found a little flaming
Amazon package
on his front porch.
[ Laughter ]
"Ew! Who would
do something like that?"
[ Laughter ]
Some political news.
Yesterday in Dallas,
former President Trump
gave a speech at CPAC,
where he said
that he didn't change
after being impeached twice
but actually became worse.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my God,
he's becoming self-aware.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's going to be
a great campaign slogan
for Trump in 2024 --
"Yep, I'm even worse."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, this is fun.
I saw that President Obama
just released his annual
summer reading list.
And not to be outdone,
President Biden
released his own
recommendations.
Here, check these out.
Obama recommends
"The Sweetness of Water,"
by Nathan Harris,
while Biden recommends
"The Crick
by Ol' Mary Walters' Barn,"
by Gil Lee.
[ Laughter ]
-Crick.
-It sounds like an older book,
but whatever.
-An older book, yeah.
-Check out another one.
Obama recommends
"Empire of Pain,"
by Patrick Radden Keefe,
while Biden recommends
an owner's manual
for a '74 Pontiac Firebird
he found at the back of a
bargain bin at Two-Toe Hutch's
Antique Depot
in Fairborn, Ohio.
He has two toes.
-Two-Toe.
-And finally, Obama recommends
"Intimacies," by Katie Kitamura,
while Biden recommends
"The Official Rulebook
for Woodchuck Bowling,"
which is where you chase
a greased-up woodchuck
around an alley
till it knocks down every pin.
First team
to knock them all down,
you get to throw the woodchuck
at the other team.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
What are you talking about?
I've never heard of that.
But it's good to know
they're both readers.
Hey, some business news tonight.
Thousands of Subway locations
across the country shut down
for a "refresh break"
to prepare for their new menu.
Yep.
They're on a refresh break.
Sounds like something
a celebrity couple would say
instead of "We broke up."
[ Laughter ]
"We're on a refresh break."
That's right,
Subway closed tonight
and used the time to pluck
all the feathers off the tuna.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Oh.
Ho-ho!
-This is amazing, though.
I saw that the deepest
swimming pool in the world
just opened in Dubai.
It's 196 feet deep.
Check this thing out.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Meanwhile the ocean was like,
"You guys know I exist, right?
I mean, you can just go --"
[ Laughter ]
"You guys want to play chess
down there?
I don't know."
[ Laughter ]
Get this.
Nearly 200 people who paid
to spend the night at a zoo
in Nebraska
have been exposed
to a rabid bat.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
[ Laughter continues ]
The zoo apologized
and offered everyone a free trip
to the next sleepover location,
a lab in Wuhan.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
We can do a sleepover trip.
[ Laughs ]
A rabid bat.
And, finally, a man in Michigan
was redoing his stairs
when he found 160 bowling balls
under his house.
Look at this thing.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
160 bowling balls,
and he still couldn't find
a 13-pound one
that fits his hand.
Well, guys, I'm so excited
about this.
The biggest band in the world,
BTS, is on the show tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Seriously,
you know you've made it
when you can order yourself
at McDonald's.
Yeah? "Hi. We'll have the us.
Thank you."
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of
the biggest pop stars,
let's get to some news.
I saw that tomorrow,
Olivia Rodrigo
is going to the White House,
and she's going to team up
with President Biden
and Dr. Fauci
to make videos
about getting vaccinated.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When his staff suggested
bringing in
popular musical artists,
Biden was like, "Great idea.
How about Glenn Miller
or the Andrews Sisters?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Up-tempo swing music plays ]
♪ Get your shot today ♪
No. I'm kidding.
Biden loves Olivia Rodrigo,
but he sings it like,
♪ I got my driver's license
63 years ago ♪
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of vaccines,
yesterday, a record number
of French citizens
booked appointments
after President Emmanuel Macron
said
you need to be vaccinated
to go to cafes.
-Ew.
-That's right.
French people were like, "If it
is for health, we will do it."
[ Laughter and applause ]
So I guess French people
were like,
"Get vaccinated
to protect my family? Non.
To eat goose liver
with strangers? Oui."
[ Laughter ]
Some more news here.
According to a new book,
early on election night, while
votes were still coming in,
Rudy Giuliani got drunk and
told Trump just to say he won.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Yeah, and if that didn't work,
Rudy's other plan was
for Trump to legally change
his name to Joe Biden.
He's like, "Boss, you did it!
You won! You're the president!"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Rudy was in
rough shape on election night.
He was slurring, sweating,
confused.
Then, he started drinking.
[ Laughter ]
Some business news -- the FCC
just gave Amazon the green light
to make a device that can
remotely monitor people's sleep.
-Ew.
[ Audience groans ]
Right, now Amazon's like, "Yeah,
now we'll start
watching you sleep.
[ Chuckles evilly ]
Yeah."
It's gonna be creepy
when Alexa is like...
-You're beautiful
when you sleep.
-That's weird. That's weird.
That's weird.
[ Laughter and applause ]
If you think this is strange,
just before you nod off,
a hologram of Jeff Bezos
kisses you good night
on the forehead.
[ Laughter ]
[ Whispering ] "Good night,
little angel."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Okay, so, he
sees you when you're sleeping.
He knows when you're awake.
And he delivers gifts.
Uh, Mom, Dad,
you can just tell me.
Is Jeff Bezos Santa Claus?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Some entertainment news.
During last night's episode of
"The Bachelorette,"
Katie introduced a new challenge
for the guys.
Listen to this.
-I kinda had this idea
that would be fun...
-Okay.
-...where the guys in the house
all have to agree to withhold
their self-care
as long as possible,
if you know what I mean.
-So, like, not do
their skin-care routine?
-Like, no shaving?
-No, we're going a little deeper
than that.
Even a little friendly handshake
with themselves are off limits.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Ugh.
I just threw up in my mouth.
-Yeah.
-What is that?
Friendly handshake
with themselves?
The weird thing is, it's one of
those long handshakes.
It's like that.
[ Laughter ]
Pbht.
Awful.
Apparently Katie got tired
of knocking on
the Fantasy Suite door
and hearing,
"Don't come in here!"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Katie said
that she wants all the guys
to refrain from being romantic
with themselves.
So, let's see how that's going
for them.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Got to leave.
-Alright, there you go.
It's an interesting episode.
[ Applause ]
I saw that, uh...
[ Laughter ]
I saw that Kraft and Van Leeuwen
teamed up
to release new limited-edition
macaroni-and-cheese
flavored ice cream.
Look at this.
[ Audience groans ]
That's great 'cause now I can
stop freezing Velveeta pouches
and eating them like Popsicles.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
officials in Minnesota
are asking residents
not to release their pet fish
into the wild after they found
football-sized goldfish
in a local lake.
This is real.
Take a look at this.
[ Audience gasps ]
It's so big,
the Discovery Channel announced
next week will be Goldfish Week.
[ Laughter ]
Seriously, you flush
your goldfish down the toilet,
then a week later,
he knocks on the door,
"It's not that easy, Brian."
[ Applause ]
The Olympics start next week,
and it was just announced
that due to COVID,
Olympians will have to take
their medals off a tray
and placed them
around their own necks.
And just like your neighbor's
house on Halloween,
the tray will have a giant sign
that says, "Please take one."
[ Laughter ]
"I want all of them.
I licked them.
Now what are you gonna do?"
Also, this is annoying.
Whoever finishes fourth
has to carry the tray.
[ Laughter ]
"I won bronze."
"I won plastic."
I'm sure it'll be fine.
I always wanted to see
Olympic medals
passed out like stuffed
mushrooms at a cocktail hour.
That's right.
They're being very cautious.
Also, when the baton
is handed off at the relay race,
you have to grab it
using a Clorox Wipe.
Not only that, the wrestlers
are going to wrestle
from six feet apart.
[ Laughter ]
Some more Olympics news --
I saw that Ralph Lauren
just unveiled
Team USA's uniforms
for the opening ceremony.
Check these out.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
They don't look like Team USA.
They look like the cast
from the "Gossip Girl" reboot.
[ Laughter ]
But get this -- these Olympics
could be the hottest on record,
so the flag bearer
is going to wear
a special white denim jacket
with a battery-powered
cooling device in it.
Take a look. Yeah.
Wait a minute, you're telling me
a white denim jacket
can get even cooler?
Impossible.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, a cooling jacket.
Or, and hear me out,
don't wear a jacket.
[ Laughter ]
Don't wear a jacket.
We're good.
It's the Olympics.
Wear a tank top.
People swim
with no shirt on.
Yeah, I mean,
it's possible, yeah.
-Flip-flops.
-Yeah.
This is very exciting.
It's time for a new segment
that we're calling
"Sleepy World Leader
of the Night,"
Angela Merkel edition.
Enjoy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Speaking German ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's fun stuff.
Some news from Washington --
the Biden administration wants
to set up a red phone with China
so the two countries
can have an emergency hotline.
Usually at Biden's age,
your emergency hotline
is hanging around your neck.
[ Laughter ]
"I've fallen --"
Yeah, we know. We know.
Meanwhile, China's like,
"Just talk loud.
We're listening
to you anyway."
Trump actually had
the same emergency phone,
but it was connected to a KFC.
[ Laughter ]
"Three buckets, all the sides,
stat."
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Trump,
a new book just came out
that describes anarchy
and chaos in the final days
of his administration.
Yeah, the final days
were anarchy and chaos
as opposed to the early days
of Omarosa and Scaramucci
that were "a well-oiled
machine," I guess.
But according to the book,
Trump said whoever leaked
the story about him
hiding in the White House bunker
during last summer's protests
should be executed.
[ Audience gasps ]
In Trump's defense, he didn't
want to stay in that bunker,
but once he went down
all those stairs,
there's no way
he's going back up.
"We're taking all the meetings
from down here.
Get me three buckets, stat.
Just throw a nugget
down the stairs."
Some controversy here --
The state of Tennessee is
making news after they decided
to stop promoting vaccines
for kids for any diseases,
including COVID.
It's pretty surprising,
and it might explain
some of their new state mottos.
Take a look at these.
Here's "Tennessee --
Come for the music,
stay for the polio."
[ Laughter ]
Now explains it.
-That's a motto.
-Here's another one --
"Tennessee, nine letters,
just like hepatitis."
[ Laughter ]
-You've got to see.
-And finally, "Tennessee --
the only medicine kids need
is Jack Daniels."
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
on last night's episode
of "The Real Housewives
of New York,"
one of the women -- I know.
They're just amazing.
It's just magic, right? Yeah.
One of the women found
an innovative way to drink wine.
Watch this.
-I never said
anything negative about her.
You can just feel like that our
relationship isn't totally
genuine -- no, not genuine,
complicated.
-Phony.
-No, I like --
-No, phony.
-[ Scoffs ]
Let me say what I want to say.
Phony.
-Let's go.
-Right now, millions of
Americans are like,
"Wait, wait, you can do that?
That would have changed
everything.
Oh, my gosh."
Even Jesus is like, "Well, do
that wine miracle thing again."
You know you could drink
through that?
I know
it's not a competition show,
but I'm pretty sure
she just won "Real Housewives."
Well, get this. I heard
about a hospital in Texas
that had two baby booms
in a row,
delivering 107 babies
in just 91 hours.
It was crazy.
The maternity ward
was like a pitching machine
at a batting cage.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, 107 deliveries
in just 91 hours.
That's not a hospital,
that's a Domino's.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys,
it's hard to believe,
but it's been over a year
since we all got on Zoom,
and yet some people are still
getting the hang of it.
Even people on TV.
So you know what that means.
It's time for another
installment of
"Greatest Moments
in Zoom History." Enjoy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay, let's call Jackie.
Hi, Jackie. How are you?
-I'm great. How are you?
-There you are. Oh.
-Flip it the other way.
-Just one more flip.
One more. One more.
-One more flip.
-Just a half a flip. Freeze.
-It's the most universal way
for all of us to stay active.
How you doing there, Matt Titus?
[ Laughter ]
-It's important to have
those protections
in place for everybody.
-Mnh-mnh. Unh-unh.
[ Laughter ]
-I think I lo-- Did I lose you?
[ Applause ]
-Finally, I saw that
US Customs officers
recently seized
489 grams of meth
that was being smuggled
in peanuts.
Here's a photo.
-Ohh.
-Well, that's one way to make
a baseball game exciting.
Police don't have a lead yet,
but they did find
something suspicious
on the Planter's
Instagram page.
Today,
German Chancellor Angela Merkel
visited President Biden
at the White House.
Yeah, Merkel was glad
to see Biden.
She said, "When I visited
the last president,
he asked if I was related
to Meghan Merkel."
[ Laughter ]
[As Trump]
"I loved 'Suits,' by the way.
I loved you on 'Suits.'"
[ Laughter ]
After 16 years in office,
Merkel's retiring this year,
and it's clear that she's ready.
When Biden brought up
the pandemic
and cyberattacks,
Merkel was like,
"Um, this seems to be
more like a you problem."
[ Laughter ]
Merkel's been in office
for Bush, Obama, Trump,
and now Biden.
At this point,
when she meets a new president,
she's just like, "Please
be normal, please be normal."
[ Laughter ]
Biden and Merkel actually
have some things in common.
They're both
respected world leaders
who also look like
vice principals
fighting over a parking space.
[ Laughter ]
But it was a great visit.
Merkel definitely seemed
more engaged with Biden
in-person than the last time,
when they met over Zoom.
Watch this.
-When I was Vice President,
they had to go down
to spring training.
And I -- It was --
Turned out it was the Yankees.
And --
-"Uh-huh, uh-huh. Yeah, yeah.
Wow."
[ Laughter ]
"Uh-huh. Oh. Oh, my goodness.
Oh, my God. That was amazing."
-"The Yankees."
-[ Laughter ]
-Everyone's talking about this.
According to a new report,
back in early 2016,
Vladimir Putin
approved a secret mission
to help Trump win the presidency
because he was
"mentally unstable"
and would weaken the U.S.
[ Audience oohs ]
Technically, what Putin said
was, "He is like Russian doll,
except when you open head,
is empty."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
The report said Trump
was "impulsive,"
"mentally unstable,"
and had an inferiority complex.
Even crazier,
they lifted that straight
from the "About the Author"
blurb in Trump's books.
[ Laughter ]
Trump said he's not unstable...
then went back to walking down
a ramp on all fours.
[ Laughter ]
"It's very slippery.
Very slippery
on leather-bottom shoes.
Very slippery."
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of
the former president,
a new book says
that top military officials
like General Mark Milley
were so worried
Trump would stage a coup
after the election,
they were all prepared
to resign.
Well, today, Trump actually
responded to General Milley.
For real.
He said, "If I was going to do
a coup, one of the last people
I would want to do it with
is General Mark Milley."
[ Laughter ]
You can tell a leader
really knows his stuff
when he uses the phrase
"do a coup."
[ Laughter ]
For the next 15 minutes,
he named all the people
he would do a coup with.
"I'd coup you. I'd coup you.
You're coup-able."
Meanwhile, during
a recent interview,
former Treasury Secretary
Steven Mnuchin struggled
to avoid saying
that Trump lost the election.
Here. Check out
Mnuchin's full statement.
First, he said, "The 2020
election is an ongoing process.
And that's all I have to say.
Thank you very mnuch."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And he kept going.
Next, Mnuchin said,
"President Trump and Mnike Pence
didn't necessarily win,
but mnany people don't believe
the mnainstream mnedia."
[ Laughter ]
And then he finally
wrapped things up.
He said, "It's time to mnove on.
So I'mma go mnake mnyself
a mnango smnoothie
and watch mny
two favorite shows --
'Mnalcolm in the Mniddle'
and
'The Mnarvelous Mnrs. Mnaisel."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckling ]
Some more news.
Next week, Jeff Bezos
is going to space,
and today it was announced that
one of his fellow passengers
is an 18-year-old.
-Ooh.
-And he will be the
youngest person ever to go.
Yeah. What an experience
for an 18-year-old.
He'll be the only passenger
who sums up the trip by saying,
"The Wi-Fi sucked."
[ Laughter ]
"Yo, you good
if I vape in here?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the 18-year-old
will take the spot
of the $28-million
mystery bidder,
who had to back out
due to "scheduling conflicts."
Scheduling conflicts.
Who's like, "Ugh.
Can't make it to space.
I forgot about my cousin's
baby shower."
[ Laughter ]
"Ugh. Let me know.
Send pictures."
[ Laughter ]
Uh, this isn't good here.
Johnson & Johnson is already
dealing with
some vaccine issues,
but now they have
a new problem on their hands.
Check this out.
-An important recall
to tell you about.
Johnson & Johnson recalling
several of its spray sunscreens.
The company says some samples
show low level of benzene,
which is a known carcinogen.
-What?! Aw, man!
That was my go-to sunscreen!
Now I have to drive to the store
and get a new bottle.
-Yeah, sorry about that, Tariq.
-It's whatever.
I don't mind driving.
I actually just bought
a new Chevy Bolt EV,
and it's pretty fun to drive.
-Oh.
-Oh, what?
-Roll the clip.
-A warning this morning.
Chevy Bolt EV owners, listen up.
Officials say some of your cars
could spontaneously catch fire.
-Oh, come -- come on!
-I'm sorry.
Look, Tariq, I'm sure
you'll find something fun
to do this summer.
-Yeah.
Yeah, I'll be fine --
as long as there's not
a recall alert tonight
involving my favorite
summer snack, blueberries,
but only if they're from Dole.
-A recall alert tonight
involving Dole blueberries
due to a possible
contamination problem.
-Man, I might as well
just drop everything and eat
thousands of marijuana-infused
chocolate edibles!
-Coming up next, why thousands
of marijuana-infused
chocolate edibles
are being recalled.
-Fine.
I'll just sit around
and play with my kids' old
Disney Baby
Winnie the Pooh rattle sets.
-The U.S. Consumer Product
Safety Commission
is issuing a recall
on the Disney
Baby Winnie the Pooh
rattle sets.
-I give up, man!
This summer is a bust!
-Hey, look on the bright side.
You just signed
a new record deal.
That's pretty exciting.
-That's true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Who did you sign with again?
-Oh, uh, Britney Spears' dad.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience oohs ]
-You know what?
Let's just move on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Finally, I heard about
a housekeeper in New Jersey
who accidentally went to the
wrong home and fully cleaned it.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, the homeowner waited
until he was done cleaning
to say, "Hey, I think
you have the wrong house."